à notre émission spéciale continue on va
analyser maintenant ce climat électrique
qui domine au Parlement que ce soit lors
des débats en hémicycle ou ce mercredi
c'était le la tonalité en commission mix
paritaire mais aussi dans la rue 8e
journée de mobilisation et France sous
tension cet arpentage de Cécile si
des heures de discussion à huis clos
dans une ambiance visiblement tendue on
nous demande de pouvoir enchaîner comme
ça et de parler des modifications
d'article 7 alors qu'on nous a remis ce
matin ce document la première mission
mixte paritaire a finalement accouché
d'un texte mais sans le vote des quatre
parlementaires de gauche très remontés
contre le gouvernement ou surtout pas
faire croire aux gens qu'il y avait
encore des marges de manœuvre en CMP
aujourd'hui tout était réglé voilà tout
était réglé et
entre la droite et la droite quoi on
fait voilà
la droite
macroniste démontre qu'elle est de
droite au cas où on n'aurait pas encore
compris côté LR on salue un texte de
compromis effectivement un rapprochement
par rapport à ce que proposait la
majorité sénatoriale et effectivement
nous sommes arrivés à un texte commun
qui prend en compte notamment les
difficultés quand on travaille plus
longtemps d'usure professionnelle aux
prises en compte de mesures de justice
sociale pour lequel pour lequel ces
mesures le Sénat a particulièrement
contribué monsieur brut-il d'accord
trouvé aujourd'hui par la commission
mixte paritaire ne signifie pas que le
texte est voté dès demain cette version
sera présentée au sénateur puis au
députés si une nouvelle fois l'une des
deux chambres ne le vote pas il
repartira en deuxième lecture devant
chaque assemblée un scénario qui espère
éviter le gouvernement sont désormais
réunies d'un accord entre la majorité et
des parlementaires d'opposition et que
cet
[Musique]
de temps en temps du positif c'est quand
même bien est-ce que pourquoi c'est une
étape si on leur pour le coup on
explique ce qui s'est passé ce qui va se
passer pourquoi c'est une étape
importante finalement avant demain il
fallait qu'elle soit conclusive est-ce
que vous pouvez rapidement nous
réexpliquer ça alors d'abord la
commission mix paritaire c'est vraiment
le lieu où peut se fabriquer le
consensus lorsqu'on n'est pas parvenu à
le fabriquer auparavant c'est d'ailleurs
la raison parce qu'on a beaucoup évoqué
cette question depuis quelques jours
c'est la raison pour laquelle tout ça se
fait à huis clos parce qu'on part du
principe que c'est dans l'intimité de
l'échange entre les 14 parlementaires
députés et sénateurs que peuvent se
faire des accords sur les textes sur
lesquels sur les articles seulement sur
lesquels il n'y a pas encore d'accord
donc c'est vraiment un moment important
en particulier sur une réforme où l'on
voit bien que les débats sont
extrêmement violents que d'ailleurs même
l'assemblée n'a finalement pas voté sur
le texte compte tenu du fait qu'on est
sur un texte de financement de la
Sécurité la CMP un peu bancale voilà ce
qui mettait les sénateurs en position
quand même favorable parce que eux
savaient sur quoi ils avaient trouvé des
intérêts d'entente et donc ce sur quoi
il pouvait avancer ou le cas échéant
négocié et la dernière raison pour
laquelle cet accord est important c'est
que toutes les CMP ne sont pas comme on
dit conclusives c'est-à-dire qu'il
arrive que à l'issue d'une commission
mix paritaire on ne parvienne pas à un
texte de synthèse là c'est vrai que les
feux étaient au vert là-dessus puisque
compte tenu de l'accord du Sénat sur une
version du texte et compte tenu de la
composition de la CMP qui était donc
plutôt majoritairement favorable à la
réforme 10 sur 14 si on prend les les
membres titulaires il y avait toutes les
raisons de penser qu'il parviendrait à
un accord Bruno cotresse ce qui était
peut-être je veux pas obligé de votre
réponse mais jouer d'avance c'était le
fait que le gouvernement ou en tout cas
les représentants de la majorité
prétentielle elle est lâcher assez vite
aux demandes de DLR quoi parce que la
majorité elle est là de toute façon on
le sait donc il y a plus de surprise de
ce côté là non il y a pas vraiment de
surprise il n'avait pas tellement de
choix il y a pas tellement d'alternative
parce qu'au fond les républicains tant
au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale ont
quand même clairement affiché la règle
du jeu par rapport au gouvernement non
absolument pas caché leur demande elles
ont été réitées à de nombreuses reprises
sur deux points assez important le
fameux CDI senior la question des
carrières longues commencer à l'âge de
20 ans 21 ans pour qu'il y ait pas de 43
années de cotisation donc les règles du
jeu étaient assez clairement établi et
ils avaient poussé leur avantage ils ont
continué de pousser leur avantage
pendant tout au long de la discussion et
ça sera d'ailleurs après coup une des
leçons politiques qu'il faudra voir
c'est à dire qu'est-ce que les
républicains font de tout ceci est-ce
qu'il considère qu'au fond ils ont gagné
quelque chose de très important ils ont
obligé l'exécutif à venir
sur leur position mais à partir de la
confond-t-il est-ce qu'il considère
qu'ils ont mis un pied dans la majorité
sera considère que c'est la réponse
demain
sur un dossier qui les motivé beaucoup
la question des retraites donc voilà une
question très importante dans les mois
qui arrivent Mathieu Souka il fallait
aussi essayer parce que c'est pas si
simple et c'est pas joué encore de
verrouiller les derniers députés LR pour
le pour le vote demain et aussi ça
l'objectif de la CMP certes mais donc
manifestement ça n'est pas tout à fait
fait et du coup la CMP effectivement je
vous rejoins c'est un vrai cours de
destruction civique pour tout le monde
désormais tout le monde sait qu'il y a
des commissions mixtes paritaires et
désormais tout le monde sait à quoi ça
sert c'était en fait le la séquence la
parenthèse de calme on pouvait alors la
CMP aurait pu elle aussi parce que les
les représentants de de des parties de
gauche voilà vous voulez que ce soit
public sont sortis régulièrement pour
communiquer avec les journalistes ont un
peu dramatisé on dit qu'ils allaient
saisir le conseil social enfin bon
c'était pas au moins calme que
d'habitude certes mais au moins la
majorité semblait acquise donc il y
avait une espèce de bulle de 24 heures
ou pour le gouvernement en tout cas des
choses paraissaient plus calme moins
incertaine alors même que dès les
prochaines heures on retombe quand même
dans une séquence d'incertitude qui est
assez troublante c'est à dire que je ne
dirai pas que la destitution du
gouvernement il y a une motion de
censure le usage du 49-3 une notion de
censure et le scénario le plus probable
il est improbable mais il n'est pas
totalement impossible et donc ça pour le
coup ça ouvre quand même ça dit quelque
chose de l'équation politique faite de
multiples inconnus dans laquelle nous
sommes pris depuis plusieurs semaines
évidemment essayez de d'analyser ces
différents scénarios scénaris pour pour
demain mais je voudrais rester encore un
peu sur cette commission mixte paritaire
avec donc je le disais des élus de
gauche sont souvent sortis pour dire
leur mécontentement tiens par exemple
Sandrine Rousseau pour Europe Écologie
Les Verts
en fait on est dans une dans un texte
qui nous a été présenté sur table à
l'arrache comme ça sans qu'on ait le
temps de le travailler à l'avance qui
présente des reculs par rapport à celui
qui nous avait déjà été présentés en
hémistique donc là ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est une forme de
prise de prise d'otages des Français et
français il faut bien dire par la par la
majorité du gouvernement qui n'ont en
rien qui est sourde et aveugle au
mouvement social qui se passe dans la
rue
en entendant cette réaction de son
vaisseau je suis très belle je me suis
quand même à l'exager parce que il y a
eu l'occasion de les étudier le texte à
l'Assemblée nationale et que toute la
stratégie de la nuque c'était pas
l'étudier oui elle-même il y a ça bien
sûr j'ajouterai par ailleurs qu'elle est
membre suppléante de la commission x
paritaire elle a été très présente
notamment à la radio et la télévision
parce qu'évidemment elle était membre
suppléante au cas où intitulaire ferait
défaut mais ça c'est de bonne guerre ce
qui est vrai c'est que avant même la
réunion qui a débuté ce matin et c'est
la logique même de la de la CMP il y a
eu des négociations si j'ose dire qui se
sont faites en amont parce que comme on
ne discute que sur les articles sur
lesquels il y a des accords l'idée c'est
quand même d'essayer de favoriser
puisque tout le monde savait qu'il y
avait qu'une journée pour faire ça de
favoriser l'accord en amont et donc
effectivement la discussion s'est
engagée sur un texte qui forcément
puisque il y a un tableau comparatif
avec déjà quelques propositions qui
forcément étaient différentes mais c'est
la règle du jeu parce que sinon c'est le
statu quo et on progresse pas alors il y
a eu dans les déclarations du jour il y
en a une moi je sais pas si vous l'avez
entendu celle d'Olivier d'exérant à la
sortie de conseil mix et il parle de
majorité naturelle si vous aviez déjà
entendu cette expression les uns et les
autres je suis pas sûr que ce soit
quelque part c'est pas constitué bon là
déjà c'est une partie de la réponse je
m'en doutais un peu Mathieu qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire en tout cas
conceptuellement on tâtonne ça c'est sûr
ça veut dire qu'on manifestement on s'en
remet à une forme de nature de Mère
Nature qui va peut-être dans les
prochains jours bien faire les choses
les images qu'on voyait à l'instant
quand même m'évoque quelque chose la
Fondation Jean Jaurès a produit hier ou
avant-hier je sais plus une dernière
étude d'Antoine bristel sur le comment
la dimension politique de tout ce qui se
passe les Français sont assez à l'aise
et même très à l'aise quel que soit leur
appartenance politique avec l'idée
d'avoir une majorité relative au
Parlement une majorité par le majorité
relative pardon au Parlement ça nous
prémunit d'un excès de pouvoir donc les
Français sont très à ceux d'ailleurs que
une une partie significative de
l'opinion et même nostalgique de la
cohabitation qui produit une forme
d'équilibre des pouvoirs pour le coup
assez naturel là en l'occurrence les
Français sont très à l'aise avec ça et
demandent de la co-construction
parlementaire les Français sont très à
l'aise avec l'idée que ils puissent y
avoir des compromis passés à l'Assemblée
entre partie ou entre groupes pour le
coup opposés dès lors que l'intérêt
général est en jeu et je ne suis pas sûr
précisément que toute la séquence que
nous venons de traverser traduisent bien
cette attente de l'opinion au contraire
la cacophonie parlementaire elle est en
voilà
intéressante sur la défiance des
Français vis-à-vis des institutions tous
les parties qui défendent
proportionnelle avec des larmes dans les
yeux à chaque élection quand ils ont
l'occasion de passer des compromis et
ben ils sont tout de suite taxés de
compromission de magouille de combine
j'ai pas le souvenir que le Parti
socialiste qui a demandé la transparence
des débats en commission mixparitaire
l'effet quand il était au pouvoir il y a
5 ans et quand la France insoumise qui
parle de magouilles et qui parle
d'opacité j'ai quand on connaît
l'opacité avec laquelle elle gère son
propre mouvement c'est quand même
particulier on est vraiment dans un jeu
d'instrumentalisation politique des
institutions on le voit bien Sandrine
Rousseau la fin de sa phrase et c'est la
photo gouvernement sourd aux Français on
peut penser ce qu'on veut de cette
réforme quel est le mal calibré mais on
est dans un dévoiement de ce qui se
passe en temps réel il y avait pas de
surprise à temps de cette commission
mise paritaire ni de nouvelles idées et
je parle sur votre contrôle parce que on
ne peut pas arriver avec une nouvelle
idée dans une commission mixte paritaire
on peut pas dire ah bah tiens si on
faisait la retraite à 66 ans ou à 63 ans
ça n'est pas possible Bruno cotress sur
le
la stratégie on va dire de la nuque à
l'Assemblée nationale ou des trois
forces de gauche au Sénat malgré une
mobilisation populaire quand même très
forte quelle analyse vous en faites
est-ce qu'il y a pas une sorte de
constat quand même de faiblesse ou
d'impuissance malgré tout ce qu'ils ont
pas pesé sur le contenu c'est clair que
ça a été tout l'enjeu du débat interne à
la nups d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
nationale de dire si on ne va pas au
bout du texte et notamment si on
n'arrive pas jusqu'à l'article central
ce fameux article 7 finalement le débat
n'a pas lieu et on n'a pas l'occasion de
faire valoir notre point de vue nos
propositions alternatives et c'est vrai
que le soutien populaire est très
important à au rejet de cette réforme
des retraites les syndicats ont été très
clairement joués très clairement le rôle
d'acteurs centraux de la société civile
en donnant un cadre en proposant des
visions aux françaises aux Français qui
sont opposés à cette réforme donc de ce
point de vue là tout un tas de
mécanismes démocratiques finalement
marche pas trop trop mal par contre
c'est dirais que du point de vue de la
transformation politique de l'essai
c'est-à-dire est-ce que il y a des
projets alternatifs quand être présenté
pleinement aux françaises et aux
Français on a un peu frustré on voit
bien qu'un 10 astuces très important en
France sur la question de travailler
plus longtemps pourquoi faire quelle est
la vision de la société qu'on a mais on
n'a pas véritablement eu une sorte de de
grand débat presse sous la forme d'un
quasi référendum en disant voilà deux
projets complètement contrastés sur
comment assurer le financement du
système de retraite par répartition en
France et de ce point de là c'est vrai
que le débat était un peu décevant
clairement alors il y a plusieurs
hypothèses je le disais on reviendra sur
celle d'un vote et d'un texte finalement
voté par une majorité sans doute courte
à l'Assemblée demain mais il y a Mathieu
ces trois chiffres qui sont sur toutes
les lèvres depuis des semaines 49-3 oui
alors ce qui est amusant c'est que son
nombre plein en fait depuis le début sur
ce débat de 49-3 qui a déjà utilisé à 10
reprises depuis le début de la
législature n'est pas d'ailleurs
étranger au choix d'un plfs rectificatif
pour porter la réforme ça offrait
l'exécutif la possibilité de le dégainer
sans griller son unique cartouche
puisqu'on rappelle que le 49-3 sont
utilisation est limitée une fois par
session sauf pour les projets de loi de
finance et de financement de la sécurité
sociale toutefois ça jamais été l'option
privilégiée par Isabelle borne qui
entendait bien montrer que sa méthode
pouvait fonctionner vous savez la
fameuse concertation qu'elle nous avait
promise dès son discours d'investiture
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'elle avait
demandé un rap de temps au président de
la République sonné pour pouvoir
négocier entre Noël et le jour de l'an
c'est aussi pour cela qu'elle grillé
toutes ses cartouches en dévoilant sa
réforme afin de sécuriser de tenter de
sécuriser un accord politique avec les
républicains et d'ailleurs le 12 janvier
elle avait même reçu en grande pompe à
Matignon le nouveau patron du parti
erikioti flanquer des présidents de
groupe Olivier Marleix et Bruno
Retailleau le sénateur de Vendée c'était
d'ailleurs félicité se repérant que les
bases d'un accord soient posées on
connaît la suite patatra si Bruno
Retailleau a tenu ses troupes et à
bénéficier du soutien actif de Gérard
Larcher et bien l'assemblée Olivier
merleix et Éric Ciotti se sont vite
laissés déborder par des députés LR je
dois le dire assez hors de contrôle
résultat des courses à la veille de la
présentation du texte assemblée bien
malin qui peut dire que le gouvernement
dispose d'une majorité ce soir et on
revoit donc planer depuis une semaine
l'ombre du 49-3 officiellement une
personne n'en veut et personne n'en veut
les syndicats ils voient
vis-hémocratiques comme la dit Laurent
Berger l'opposition un coup de force
quant au gouvernement vous avez vu comme
moi tous les ministres défilés cette
semaine sur les plateaux des matinales
pour dire qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas y
recourir mais à l'inverse bâtir une
majorité et entre nous on comprend un
peu tout ce monde-là parce que le 49 3
d'accord c'est un outil constitutionnel
qui a été maintes fois utilisé par le
passé mais là ce sont les circonstances
politiques qui à mes yeux sont
exceptionnels la procédure parlementaire
à marche forcée choisie par le
gouvernement les débats abordés et le
vote du coup torpillé j'allais dire
empêcher à l'Assemblée nationale la
tenue d'une CMP est quand même
unijambiste puisque les députés ne sont
pas arrivés avec un texte pour le pour
la bonne raison qu'il ne l'avait pas
examiné si vous ajoutez à ça les
centaines de milliers de Français qui
ont manifesté pour protester contre un
texte qui par ailleurs et singulièrement
et régulièrement des avouer par le tiers
de l'opinion dans toutes les enquêtes et
les sondages qui ont été publiés alors
si vous rajoutez dernière couche un
dernier coup de menton ça serait le
pompon faut rappeler que jamais une
grande réforme sur un tel enjeu de
société n'a ainsi été imposé et pourtant
le gouvernement pourrait être contraint
d'y recourir si la majorité sur ce texte
ce soir demain matin s'avère trop courte
ou impossible à trouver il est encore
possible de convoquer un conseil des
ministres exceptionnels un ténor LR hier
favorable à la réforme me disait il y a
une semaine le gouvernement le
gouvernement avait encore le choix entre
la Grosse Bertha du 49-3 ou la roulette
russe du vote à l'assemblée mais le
problème ajoutait-il c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la roulette russe est
devenue une roulette belge avec une
balle dans chaque chambre
on va faire un peu d'histoire quand même
parce qu'aujourd'hui Mathieu l'a dit le
49-3 synonyme de passage en force
d'opinion pourquoi il a été créé dans
dans la constitution de 58 faut juste le
rappeler c'est après pour le dire en des
termes très juridiques c'est un des
instruments de ce qu'on appelle la
rationalisation du parlementarisme donc
l'idée elle est la suivante c'est
souvent la formule que j'utilise avec
mes étudiants c'est rendre le régime
parlementaire raisonnable et je ne dis
pas ça juste pour jouer sur les mots le
fait est que on sait que en régime
parlementaire et en tout cas la pratique
française du régime parlementaire
jusqu'en 1958 a conduit à une très
grande instabilité gouvernementale si on
prend ne serait-ce que la quatrième 12
ans 25 gouvernements donc une durée de
vie moyenne de gouvernement qui est
autour de six mois mais en réalité
certains durent beaucoup plus et
d'autres quelques jours et la Troisième
République était à cet égard à peine
mieux moyennant quoi la difficulté
principale de l'instabilité
gouvernementale c'est pas tant la
succession le gouvernement c'est aussi
des périodes sans gouvernement
c'est-à-dire les périodes pendant
lesquelles en réalité on ne peut pas
gouverner le pays et l'obsession du
général de Gaulle dans le contexte dans
lequel il revient au pouvoir mais plus
largement des des gaullistes à cette
époque c'est vraiment de garantir que le
pays puisse être gouverné au long cours
donc on crée toute une série de
procédures parmi lesquelles l'article 49
alinéa 3 qui va permettre de
forcer la main en quelque sorte d'une
majorité alors soit absolue mais avec à
l'intérieur des frondeurs je rappelle
que 49 3 a pu être utilisé à cette fin
soit effectivement quand on a une
majorité relative et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que fait aussi Michel Debré au tout
début parce que on l'oublie souvent au
début de la cinquième République il y a
une majorité relative et j'ajoute que ça
n'est pas purement français parce que
chaque régime parlementaire peut avoir
des systèmes comme cela un exemple
l'Allemagne consiste souvent en disant
ça se passe beaucoup mieux là-bas
l'Allemagne a une motion de censure elle
et la motion de censure exige par
exemple exemple que pour renverser le
gouvernement soit capable de donner le
nom du chancelier qui succédera celui
qu'on renverse ce qui est quand même une
contrainte qui n'est pas négligeable
donc on voit bien que chaque pays a
adapté si j'ose dire à sa culture
politique des instruments juridiques
Olivier vérante-parole du gouvernement
affirmé à l'issue du conseil ministre
toujours que l'hypothèse du 49-3 il n'y
avait pas été évoqué Matthieu de le
croire
je ne sais pas je n'étais pas au je
n'étais pas au Conseil des ministres
c'est forcé ça fait forcément partie
enfin voilà c'est c'est dans la dans la
gamme des stratégies
il faut il va falloir convoquer un
conseil de ministre extraordinaire pour
pouvoir l'utiliser
l'inconfort l'inconfort tient quand même
au fait que s'il n'y a pas de majorité
pour cette réforme dans le pays pas du
tout même normalement il y a une
majorité au Parlement pour cette réforme
encore une fois le débat politique a eu
lieu il y a six mois à l'occasion de
l'élection présidentielle la majorité
gouvernementale et les LR la majorité
des LR normalement l'adopte alors on a
découvert que s'il y avait des frondeurs
à gauche il y a en fait aussi des
frondeurs à droite et donc c'est toute
la difficulté et tout le monde du coup
est affront renversé tout le monde est à
fond renversé
vous vous on est dans les scénarios le
scénario 49-3 c'est peut-être pas le
pire mais pas loin c'est ça c'est un des
pires effectivement parce que
dans l'ordre du pire il me semble que le
pire politiquement pour le gouvernement
serait que le texte arrive au vote et
que le gouvernement se prenne en direct
qui n'a pas de majorité parce que là
c'est perdant perdant on pensait la voix
puis il y a trois défauts
ça souligne peut-être le manque de sens
de l'analyse du de l'exécutif ça
soulignera encore plus le manque
d'assise de la réforme par rapport non
seulement à l'option publique mais aux
représentants du peuple donc là c'est
terrible le 49-3 il a une marque de
fabrique effectivement qui ça vient être
rappelé à de bonnes raisons qui étaient
ce parlementarisme rationalisé par
contre c'est vrai qu'il a pris une très
mauvaise réputation et qu'il est symbole
dans l'option publique d'un excès de
pouvoir de l'exécutif d'un refus du
débat démocratique et c'est vrai qu'il a
comme conséquence de stopper net le
débat parlementaire donc c'est vrai
qu'il a très mauvaise réputation et
cette mauvaise réputation je dirais n'a
fait peut-être aujourd'hui que que
s'accentuer dans un pays qui a ce
sentiment d'un écart entre la sphère du
politique et les demandes sociales les
demandes des des citoyens et aussi dans
un contexte un peu plus général ou
s'exprime dans le pays des demandes de
faire respirer la démocratie de
davantage consulter de davantage de
démocratie directe davantage de
démocratie par le bas participatif des
libératives etc et donc c'est vrai que
de ce point de vue là ça enverrait un
signal qui serait un signal peut-être
long et douloureux à digérer j'ai oublié
tout à l'heure mais il y en a
quelques-uns que ça arrangerait quand
même c'est certain côté LR qui sont pas
forcément contre ça très forme mais qui
ne veulent pas le prendre le risque de
la voter pour avoir ensuite rendre des
comptes dans leur circonscriptions et se
satisfait assez bien à 49-3 le 1 un
complément peut être choisi l'usage du
49-3 effectivement à ajouter à
l'instruction du procès en arrogant et
en déconnexion du pouvoir mais il y a
une autre dimension aussi il y a un
indicateur que j'aime citer quand en
général j'utilise comme un indicateur de
populisme 90% des Français 88% pour être
précis en fait pensent que c'est dans
l'enquête fracture française de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès 88% des Français
pensent que nos gouvernements en fait
prennent de mauvaises décisions
gouvernement et prennent de mauvaises
décisions au sens où elles sont
contraires lors des décisions sont
contraires aux intérêts en fait du
peuple et pire que cela en fait la
moitié d'entre eux pensent que cette à
dessin que ces volontaires qu'il n'y a
pas seulement en fait une faillite ou
une défaillance des élites qu'il y a une
trahison des élites on peut rappeler que
cet article 49.3 il a déjà été modifié
c'est ce Nicolas Sarkozy c'est ça alors
je d'abord peut-être je voulais rappeler
le prolongement de ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure que quand on dit il faut une
majorité pour le texte où il faudrait
pas être majorité contre là on est dans
une logique de majorité relative pour le
vote qui aura lieu demain c'est-à-dire
qu'il suffit qu'il y en ait plus pour
que de contre pour que ça passe pas
nécessairement une majorité renforcée de
289 voix comme on le dit parfois comme
par exemple pour une motion de censure
et qu'évidemment le problème serait que
il y ait plus de vote contre que pour
quel que soit leur seuil sachant que et
ça rejoint ce que vous disiez il y a
aussi des abstentions probables parce
que dans ces cas là ça peut être plus
prudent en quelque sorte on assume pas
son vote voilà alors si je reviens sur
le sur le 49-3 en réalité pendant
longtemps il n'a pas eu la mauvaise
presse qu'il a aujourd'hui et d'une
certaine manière c'est à partir de 2007
qu'il prend une très mauvaise presse
pour deux raisons la première c'est que
Nicolas Sarkozy au moment où il lance le
processus de révision de la Constitution
comme il a une majorité absolue très
forte à l'Assemblée d'une part dit que
lui ne l'utilisera jamais alors il dit
lui alors qu'en réalité évidemment c'est
son premier François Fillon n'utilisera
pas et n'hésitera pas à le dire parce
qu'ils ont fait en quelque sorte
l'illustration de sa force politique et
dans ce mouvement là Nicolas Sarkozy
envisage à un moment purement et
simplement de le supprimer et c'est mis
en débat au moment du la préparation de
la réforme et finalement c'est j'allais
dire la sagesse des parlementaires qui
pourtant pourrait en été première
victime que de dire ne préjugeons pas de
l'avenir ça a été utile à certains
moments donc on va en resserrer le
périmètre les textes budgétaires donc
projet de loi de finance projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
les textes rectificatifs éventuels comme
c'est le cas qu'on voit aujourd'hui plus
un texte sur n'importe quel sujet au
choix du gouvernement pendant la session
alors d'ici à demain le téléphone de
certains députés va continuer de sonner
on peut l'imaginer des députés LR des
députés du groupe lyaute qui compte
notamment des élus d'outre-mer
tractations dénoncé par Thomas ménag et
là des 89 et élus députés du
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée on
le sait on a des retours depuis hier qui
sont quand même très importants des
députés des républicains des députés de
l'iode qui sont achetés c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui nous avons un gouvernement
des ministres qui avec l'argent public
avec l'argent des Français sont en train
d'acheter des voix acheter des
abstentions on est dans une sorte de
République où on achète des voix
alors j'ai volontairement gardé ce genre
pour qu'on puisse le décortiquer Mathieu
parce que là on a l'impression que c'est
le député qui se fait acheter voilà
c'est avec des données publiques mais
mais faut quand même pour convaincre un
député récapitrant il y a pas 36 moyens
on peut menacer d'abord on peut lui dire
si tu continues comme ça tu te fais
exclure quand il est dans sa majorité où
on te reconduit pas on te redonnera pas
ton investiture si tu te représente si
c'est un adversaire on peut lui dire on
va mettre quelqu'un devant toi mais qui
va te pulvériser enfin bref il y a un
jeu de pression et puis pousser des
projets pour le territoire voilà et les
carottes c'est du moins tu as toujours
besoin de ta subvention pour alors on le
présente généralement est-ce que tu as
besoin de quelque chose ou le président
apprécie beaucoup ce que tu fais il
pense à toi pour voilà donc il y a toute
une série mais imaginez qu'on achète
comme c'est dit un peu rapidement par
Thomas ménagé non il y a pas de jusqu'à
preuve du contraire j'ai pas le souvenir
de ministre et acheter des voix avec
cette que ce soit avec ces deux dieux
personnels ou c'est deniers des données
publiques un parlementaires Mathieu
souker c'est moi ça me fait penser
évidemment aux États-Unis où il y a
comme ça régulièrement dans l'actualité
un ou deux
représentants du peuple qui se retrouve
avec le pouvoir de faire passer ou pas
un texte important là-bas ça choque
personne ici ici bah voilà alors on peut
je sais pas lequel des deux pays a
raison mais non pas ça passe aux
États-Unis et pas ici mais je suis pas
sûr que ça choque ici non plus ce qui
questionne aujourd'hui encore une fois
c'est que une tambouille soit nécessaire
ou en tout cas des discussions des
négociations soient nécessaires avec une
partie des députés qui devrait
naturellement pour reprendre le terme de
tout à l'heure soutenir personnalité
cette réforme c'est ça qui paraît
totalement incompréhensible la cohérence
l'incohérence en politique ça se paye
donc on pourrait imaginer là qu'il y ait
quand même une forme de cohérence et on
a même précisément une partie DLR qui
ont visé à adoucir la réforme disait-il
à en faire comme dirait Olivier du soft
absolument une réforme de gauche pour
ensuite que Bruno Retailleau dise non
attention fin de la récré c'est vraiment
une réforme de droite c'est ce qui fait
qu'on s'y perd alors pourquoi y a-t-il
ces hésitations parce que évidemment les
députés sont confrontés à l'opinion dans
leur circonscriptions et et
effectivement ça dit bien en réalité que
non seulement l'opinion est très
majoritairement hostile à la réforme
mais ça tient au fait que au cours des
dernières semaines j'imagine que vous
avez eu ça aussi je pense notamment à
une enquête d'Harry interactive qui
l’instruit qui le documente la
proportion de Français très hostile à la
réforme a quasiment doublé donc on voit
bien que sur le terrain on comprend en
tout cas que pour les députés soit à
partir du moment difficiles parce que on
n'est plus dans une forme d'hésitation
de résistance on est dans une hostilité
très grande que confirme d'ailleurs tous
les leaders syndicaux en disant dans les
manifestations on ressent une colère
très forte dont on imagine qu'elle
pourrait réellement déborder et y
compris les leaders syndicaux disent que
ils ont rarement vu en fait un tel
niveau de tension alors cette fin
d'après-midi cette dépêche de l'agence
frange France Presse nous apprend que le
Président de la République Emmanuel
Macron réunit ce mercredi soir à
l'Élysée la première ministre Elisabeth
borne les principaux ministres concernés
par la réforme des retraites elle avait
du vote au Parlement sera d'abord au
Sénat puis on compte c'est ça Mathieu on
sort la calculette parce que c'est c'est
ce soir qu'en gros ils vont décider on
sait qu'il ne souhaite pas le 49-3 il
faut le dire mais c'est ce soir qui vont
se dire est-ce qu'on une forme de coup
de poker quand même parce que comme vous
le disiez justement on est c'est vrai
qu'on est pas à la majorité 289
d'ailleurs 287 parce que il y a des il y
a des sièges vacants mais c'est un vrai
coup de poker parce que la psychologie
de base étage mais est-ce que c'est dans
la bien dans l'état d'esprit d'un
Emmanuel Macron
et on le sait frustré de ne pas avoir pu
jouer il y a quelques années au moment
de la présentation de la loi mais oui
alors il faut il faut ajouter en plus
que tel que les choses sont mises en
place à ce stade il y a plusieurs
options il y a le 49-3 tout de suite
c'est à dire pour éviter effectivement
le cas échéant le rejet demain par
l'assemblée du texte adopté en CMP mais
si jamais l'assemblée demain rejette le
texte votait en CMP il y a toujours la
possibilité d'un 49-3 après alors je
vous interrompre parce que c'est en
partie le thème de la chronique de
Mathias ça reste je vous donnerai la
réponse juste après Mathias bienvenue
rebonsoir donc le texte on l'a dit doit
être voté demain matin au Sénat puis à
l'Assemblée nationale que se
passerait-il s'il était rejeté par les
deux alors on repartirait pour voir
l'une des deux chambres par l'une des
deux chambres on repartirait pour un
deuxième tour Thomas c'est ce que
prévoit la procédure de la navette
parlementaire en cas d'échec ou de rejet
du texte de la CMP on doit procéder à
une nouvelle lecture par chaque
assemblée l'ordre d'examen devrait
rester le même c'est à dire un Assemblée
nationale de Sénat avant une adoption
définitive par l'Assemblée nationale que
le texte resterait soumis à l'article
47.1 de la Constitution avec cette
réduction de du temps des débats il est
débats resteraient limités dans le temps
50 jours au total après le dépôt du
projet de loi voilà ce que dit l'article
47 1 de la Constitution que vous citez
Thomas donc au plus tard le texte doit
avoir été voté au Sénat deuxième chambre
à l'examiner dimanche 26 mars à minuit à
noter Thomas que s'il devait y avoir
rejet de la version de la CNP cela
interviendrait demain il en resterait
alors dix jours tout au plus pour une
deuxième lecture sans précision sur la
répartition des jours entre les deux
chambres mais en réalité une nouvelle
lecture ne dure en général qu'un jour
j'ai bien dit en général et si aucune
des chambres ne se prononce sur le texte
en seconde lecture et bien si ce délai
de 50 jours est dépassé sans que le
texte n'était voté que la Constitution
prévoit que les dispositions du projet
peuvent être mises en œuvre par Ordonn
on peut voir cette option comme un
facilitateur mais en réalité même au
sein de la majorité présidentielle
Thomas on espère éviter ce mécanisme qui
pourrait être perçu comme plus brutal
qu'un 49-3 merci beaucoup Mathias and
lovajo je reviens vers vous qu'il a un
peu fait votre job Mathias mais bon
merci ça permet d'être voilà d'être le
plus pédagogique possible pour pour
noter les spectateurs le je reviens sur
la question des ordonnances c'est déjà
arrivé sur un texte d'une telle
importance que on au bout de du
processus on passe par des alors là
encore on est vraiment dans la logique
qui a été voulue en 1958 c'est à dire
qu'on sait très bien que le moment le
plus difficile pour un gouvernement qui
est en position fragile et là je me
place expérience de la quatrième ou de
la Troisième République c'est le vote du
budget parce que effectivement parliez
tout à l'heure des États-Unis on sait
bien on adore parler en France du
Lockdown américain c'est à ce moment où
le budget n'est pas voté et où bah on
est au sens du terme en cessation de
paiement on l'avait connu nous sous la
troisième et la Quatrième République
donc en 1958 l'idée et de ne pas courir
ce risque et même de dissuader les
parlementaires de faire courir ce risque
au gouvernement puisque de toute façon
ne pas voter le budget et sans effet
puisque on peut le faire rentrer en
vigueur par ordonnance en l'état du
projet deuxième chose quand on a conçu
les lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale on les a alignés sur les lois de
finances donc on a mis en place le même
système parce qu'il y a les mêmes
contraintes de durée puisque l'année
budgétaire commence au 1er janvier et
que l'idée est de là encore éviter un
blocage parlementaire et quand on a une
loi de finance rectificative ou une noix
de financement rectificative comme celle
qu'on a aujourd'hui sur les retraites et
bien c'est une possibilité alors oui ça
a pu se faire ça a pu se faire
ponctuellement par exemple quand il y a
eu un retard ou même une censure totale
du texte par le Conseil constitutionnel
dans les années 70 donc pour éviter
d'être sans budget sur les lois de
finances on fait entrer en vigueur mais
en réalité réalité sur un texte comme
celui des retraites on voit bien que le
véhicule législatif qui a été retenu
avait comme qualité pour le gouvernement
de pouvoir contraindre le temps du débat
parlementaire donc évitez l'obstruction
mais sur un plan politique ce serait
alors là peut-être encore pire que ce
que disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
un texte qui non seulement n'est pas
voté mais qui même est rejeté et que le
gouvernement fait quand même entrer en
vigueur alors là on est un peu dans le
registre de la de la dissuasion si j'ose
dire je reviens juste aussi d'un mot sur
la Réunion qui aurait lieu là en ce
moment même à l'Elysée il faut pas
oublier non plus que demain le texte qui
va être discuté par le Sénat puis
l'assemblée est un texte auquel le cas
échéant le gouvernement peut seul encore
apporter des amendements donc ça veut
dire qu'il peut aussi y avoir une
discussion sur le cas échéant avant le
vote de demain des modifications à la au
texte de la CMP pour justement accroître
les possibilités d'accord venant par
exemple de LR convaincre les derniers
réticent on va s'appuyer Bruno comme
prévu sur ce cette étude menée par le
cevipop pour illustrer vous l'avez un
peu évoqué mais le le la défiance on va
dire grandissante des des Français pour
nos institutions
je vous propose de d'afficher comme ça
au fur et à mesure les les résultats
c'est une baisse de 7 points pour le
Sénat baisse donc la question c'est
avez-vous confiance c'est tout simple
dans le Sénat moins 7 points c'est moins
10 points pour l'Assemblée nationale le
Président de la République c'est moins 8
le gouvernement c'est -9 comment vous
analysez ces une certaine manière on
voit que Paul opinion on est en train de
refermer la parenthèse covid et on le
voit dans deux dimensions d'un autre
enquête la première dimension c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup moins de pression sur
le ressenti psychologique personnel on a
des indicateurs sur le sentiment de
sérénité de bien-être qui sont à la
hausse ils avaient considérablement
chuté depuis le printemps de 2020 il
repartent à la hausse voire beaucoup à
la hausse et on a exactement la même
chose qui s'était produite au fond entre
les gilets jaunes et juste avant le
covid ou les indicateurs de bien-être
personnels étaient repartis à la hausse
et puis la parenthèse covid se referme
aussi mais pour le politique et sur le
politique on peut voir que c'est
vraiment presque lors des réglement de
compte c'est à dire que le soutien donne
qui avait le surcroît de soutien qui
avait été donné à l'exécutif au titre de
ben voilà quand même un exécutif qui
finalement protège qui a sur son rôle
pendant une période de pandémie
absolument incroyable là on voit qu'on
revient à l'ordinaire de la défiance
politique à la française mais tout le
monde en prend pour son grade et y
compris les pouvoirs au niveau local
conseil municipal maire qui reste
toujours en tête donc classement des
conférences mais qui chute beaucoup
voire de -8 - 10 points et donc on voit
une sorte de de de tout le monde perdant
de ce point de vue là la défiance
française est en train de reprendre ses
lettres de noblesse si je puis dire et
envoie à nouveau s'exprimer dans toutes
les indications et dans toutes les
dimensions de notre de notre enquête un
exécutif français qui sort un peu en
lambeaux de la période d'aujourd'hui
avec une popularité un soutien à
l'action de l'exécutif qui est faible en
la comparé à l'Allemagne à l'Italie au
Royaume-Uni on a 50%
d'approbation sur Georgia Meloni on est
à 26% pour Emmanuel Macron c'est pas
exactement comparable parce qu'ils sont
pas au même stade évidemment de leur
mandature mais on voit quand même que la
France retrouve ce syndrome de
sinistrose politique on a commencé en
parlant finalement de la pédagogie
parlementaire que que la séquence permet
alors nous évidemment c'est notre rôle
mais d'une manière générale aux médias
de de faire Matthieu souker est-ce qu'on
peut dans les résultats que vous donnez
je rappelle moi moins 7 points dans la
confiance du pour le Sénat moins 10 pour
l'Assemblée nationale il y a pas quand
même une occasion manquée pour le pour
le Parlement la vraie tragédie on était
elle est là alors je dis pas que pour
l'exécutif c'est on pouvait sans doute
s'y attendre mais mais c'est vrai que
c'est une
occasion totalement ratée on pouvait
renouer avec une forme de culture
parlementaire qui est encore une fois ce
qui est plutôt à l'opinion on évoquait
le 49-3 et l'esprit de la Cinquième
République l'opinion a singulièrement
évolué évidemment depuis 1958 et en
particulier la verticalité du pouvoir et
les passages en force qui à l'époque
était précisément associé à l'image d'un
pouvoir crédible d'un pouvoir légitime
tout ça ça ne plaît plus du tout à
l'opinion et on parlait tout à l'heure
effectivement du fait que les Français
étaient en attente de co-construction au
Parlement d'un esprit de compromis etc
on observe que y compris chez les
sympathisants de la France insoumise
c'est partager c'est à dire que il n'y a
qu'à la France insoumise qu'une partie
des sympathisants et pour une opposition
radicale frontale l'expression d'une
forme de colère au Parlement mais même à
la France insoumise en réalité les
sympathisants sont divisés et la moitié
d'entre eux prône la co-construction
l'esprit de dialogue et l'esprit de
compromis et dernière chose pardon là
dessus quand Elisabeth borne est arrivé
à son poste à Matignon c'était en
particulier ou en tout cas il y avait un
début d'identité politique autour du
fait que elle allait être quelqu'un de
solide à à poil qui allait tenir les
dossiers tenir les troupes et deuxième
dimension porteuse soi-disant d'un
esprit de dialogue en particulier parce
qu'au ministère du Travail à l'avait su
discuter avec les syndicats etc on voit
que tant du côté du dialogue social que
du débat que du côté du débat
parlementaire sans accablés Elisabeth
borne c'est plus difficile en tout cas
que ce qu'on identité ce que son
identité politique initiale disait alors
que ça correspond pas forcément à ce
qu'elle a montré depuis six mois puisque
depuis six mois elle a fait passer des
textes avec la gauche avec la droite
enfin avec la gauche sur les énergies
avec la droite sur la Lamy on verra ce
qu'il advient de l'immigration mais elle
a quand même réussi des facto cette
co-construction ou cette concertation
pendant 6 mois ce qui était ce que pas
gagné parce qu'on était pas beaucoup
mais je me suis affreux que tout le
monde disait ça ça marchera mais là le
dossier retraite ça cache tout ça ça va
abîmer considérablement l'image de
l'exécutif tout le monde y perd
l'exécutif hyper les républicains ont
tout perdu en crédibilité ils
défendaient quand même les 65 ans pour
la campagne présidentielle quand on leur
donne la possibilité de faire une
retraite ils disent non il faut baisser
ça veut dire que c'est des gens qui
croient pas ce qui raconte six mois
avant la gauche elle a perdu une
occasion terrible à mon avis l'assemblée
refusant de discuter et de voter
l'article 7 parce qu'à l'époque
peut-être que l'article s'est arrêté et
s'ils avaient été jusqu'au bout du texte
les députés à la Commission xperitaire
aurait eu plus de poids pour négocier un
texte
oui alors c'est tout à fait vrai en même
temps on sait que au moins depuis 1995
cette question des retraites est un
dossier quasiment ingérable intenable et
sur lequel les gouvernements d'une
manière ou d'une autre but pas forcément
chute mais but c'est clair et on sait
qu'on sera jamais populaire donc ça
c'est quand même la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que oui
effectivement c'est une occasion manquée
institutionnellement c'est à dire que
alors même que pour la première fois
depuis un temps certain on avait on a
une assemblée dans laquelle une majorité
relative et que on nous dit qu'il y a
une appétence pour effectivement de la
conciliation la concertation etc l'A n'a
pas réussi à en faire preuve mais en
même temps pardon
parallèle
moi ce que j'observe c'est que beaucoup
des élus de juin 2022 donc des députés
qui ont été élus sont aussi des députés
qui en ont appelé soit à la rue soit au
référendum et qui donc d'une certaine
manière eux-mêmes déni à la
représentation la mission qui est la
sienne et donc se mettent
individuellement et donc forcément
collectivement en difficulté puisqu'il
nous explique ça n'est pas à nous de
décider il faut que ce soit le peuple il
y a eu plusieurs motions référendaires
ce qui est quand même pas très habituel
ou bien il faut puisque la rue s'insurge
il faut qu'on entende la rue alors même
qu'ils ont la possibilité débattre sur
le texte donc je crois que c'est plus
fondamentalement même si c'est presque
une vieille rengaine la crise de la
représentation qui aujourd'hui touche je
crois un point presque de non-retours il
y a Bruno aussi une question sur la
démocratie est-ce que notre démocratie
fonctionne là aussi les résultats sont
on a un indicateur qui est posé dans le
monde entier pratiquement c'est un
indicateur international que tous les
chercheurs posent dans les enquêtes sur
le rapport des citoyens au système
politique est-ce qu'on dirait que le
système démocratique la démocratie
fonctionne bien dans le pays l'opinion
négative en France est toujours
majoritaire et c'était légèrement pas
bien c'était légèrement réfléchi depuis
l'élection d'Emmanuel Macron on voyait
qu'il y avait un peu mieux un peu plus
de Français disant oui la démocratie
fonctionne mais là on repart à la hausse
et on est pratiquement à l'ordre de 70%
qui disent que la démocratie en France
ne fonctionne pas bien et on a d'autres
indicateurs dans notre enquête la
demande pour l'idée que peut-être moins
de démocratie pour plus d'efficacité
nous étions montés à plus de 40% l'an
dernier on est toujours de l'ordre un
peu plus de 30% sur cet item donc il y a
quand même plus d'un tiers des Français
qui disent moins de démocratie pour plus
d'efficacité donc le système
démocratique donne le sentiment qui ne
répond pas bien aux attentes qui
répondent pas bien au problème on va
donner la parole à l'un des manifestants
de d'aujourd'hui dans les rues de Paris
c'est un enseignant il est enseignant en
Lycée Professionnel à Caudry s'appelle
Nicolas brûlant et il est sur ce thème
de finalement de ce qu'il attend lui de
la politique j'attends plus rien je
serai pour une démocratie plus directe
comprenne la vie des citoyens quoi
faudrait un référendum sur cette
question et là les gens se prononcent ça
passe ça passe pas mais il y aurait plus
de discussion et je pense que ça se
plaira dans les yeux urnes et pour moi
c'est très très pareil c'est très sombre
le Front national monte de plus en plus
et pour moi c'est pas une solution
dans le Nord et pas du tout à Paris donc
je c'était pas à Paris c'était dans
l'ordre il y a eu encore des
manifestations un peu partout en France
Mathieu Souquet on va terminer là-dessus
sur le est-ce que cette séquence parce
que je sais que vous êtes assez
sceptique là c'est cette séquence elle
peut finalement infidélité profiter à
qui aura sûrement national alors oui en
dernier ressort ça me semble à qui en
tout état de cause on voit que Emmanuel
Macron quel que soit le scénario de ses
prochains jours de toute façon sortira
affaibli la séquence je ne vois pas que
la nupaisse à travers la posture
tactique qu'elle a affiché ou les LR
avec la confusion qu'ils ont su
entretenir sur le fond en fait en sorte
grandi alors à court terme je ne suis
pas sûr non plus que Marine Le Pen
elle-même tirait énormément de bénéfices
de ce qui s'est passé à court terme en
tout cas on ne peut pas dire que le
rassemblement national à l'Assemblée est
brillé par la qualité de ses
interventions la pertinence de ces
propositions la cohérence de son projet
on sait que elle-même Marine Le Pen a
évolué un poulpe reprise sur la question
des retraites donc je ne suis pas sûr
que là-dessus elle est affiché une forme
d'autorité en revanche il est évident
que ce que la séquence traduit en fait
va probablement va probablement va très
certainement même alimenter et le
sentiment de défiance et une forme de
mal-être dans l'opinion qui est encore
une fois voit cette réforme des
retraites comme une amputation de
quelque chose qui était perçu
positivement donc voilà à la fin on
imagine bien que c'est ce qui fait en
général le vin de l'extrême droite qui
va continuer de prospérer le prochain
scrutin le vase sont des sénatoriales
pas doucement pas franchement favorable
a priori à ce moment national c'est
plutôt les européennes où on pourrait
avoir où on pourrait avoir effectivement
un
sursaut encore plus fort alors ce qui
est vrai aussi c'est que je crois que au
niveau national la position aujourd'hui
de RN elle est un peu paradoxale parce
que à la fois elle se légit il se
légitimise si j'ose dire c'est il
s'institutionnalise et donc il peut
aussi susciter du coup le rejet dont il
était porteur à l'égard des institutions
donc effectivement l'analyse par les
électeurs sera intéressante mais c'est
vrai que le les élections européennes
sont toujours le bon moment pour les
anti-européanistes qui sont merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à cette émission
je vous dis à demain évidemment pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et puis
notez que Bruno Retailleau le président
du groupe LR au Sénat sera l'invité de
la matinale rien de Mancini ce sera à 8h
ou non Retailleau dans le domicile a été
plongé dans le noir voilà ce n'est ni le
premier ni le dernier mais ça fait
partie des petites de cette fin
d'après-midi belle soirée à tous